спробуй дружину 5000 рублів
спробуй дотягну 7 тисяч сміхотворних
штрафу про рахунок у 80 та 110 євро за
закону про декриміналізацію таки
протести в Росії на базі не тільки
разил їм видно вали біля дроту не звучали
демонстрації us ще дозволяється їм
активістам закон з індивідуально
коткування вигляд станеш про
фестивальний комі моя but i 50 метрів я
качок хід штрафи менше тим же
нелегально демонстрація ради федерації
прикольний до поправок з 3g через це
по клас ти вкрай про партійним поки
ранимо за так звання признач не акти на
засоби для тих хто sky у них у porsche
мовляв чини закон зручності вже час 2
чаду стати не захотіло щеня а проблема
пологової спадщини не їду ж по
шириною у нас сьогодні сім'я на сьогодні
руди на зміну зводиться і переїздом на
виходу пак безтурботними c1000 у нас
порушується проблема що воно за добрий
русів нічого подібного не травня так то це
дуже великими тобто це дуже великий
міф соромно взводний анастасія
царева її організація педро до волоча в
Росії широку близько 14 тисяч ж ніг
адже помирає насильства збоку своїх
партнерів
анастасія вкотре пішла компанію за право
ніг пресвятого аяксом набуду волосся
адже домашнього насильства хоч у мене
ось тут принцип туман і ось тут же
лося та за штани там було до виходу
тільки сходу ніг 10 мабуть queen що
фруман його так головою paradise ході я
впала в палашка rebirth пляма вояку ми з
юнакові велике піднімався
піднімався на хліб за рахунок двох ти мені
піднятися ще вадим сказав на чапаєва на
п'яна метрова вона п'яна студії налити
на думку нас стеля повернулися до поліції
за допомогою чудовисько navitel на було
покарання кіза раз становлення та мати
but is косого нею ніхто не
ніхто тижнів після пішов удару
піддаватися заяву tab вулиці та не я хочу
жінка дійшла до поліції з позначає їй
душу ркц означаючи ще спадщину ж
відриваючи на ph і дай або пішли ти ж не
мірою анастасія здається продовжив це та
боротьбу щоб ти пожартував
не ціла що кручена підпише президент
путін поправкою до закону дарства чинить